babes I am on tour right now with the
guys tickets are available at
impracticaljokerslive.com a bunch of
cities up there cities always being
added later on in the month we got Green
Bay Milwaukee Rosemont then we're
heading over to Seattle Portland where
we head to the show uh so on and so
forth Bangor Maine extra show in Boston
is added all right now on
practicaljokerslive.com and the show is
on every single Thursday night 10
o'clock Eastern on TBS and TruTV all new
episodes season 10 check it out we love
you babe
I appreciate it New York City Radio City
Music Hall sold out in just 10 days on
September 22nd so we've added a show
September 23rd at the theater at Madison
Square Garden those tickets are on sale
at christycomedy.com New York City come
on out most of my shows thank you so
much are sold out the ones that aren't
then we have March 29th one of the shows
at West Palm Beach has tickets available
uh Austin Texas April I'm sorry no
that's sold out April 13th San Antonio
Texas we have tickets available The Late
Show May 5th and buffalo has tickets May
6th and Ithaca has tickets and
um that's it so I appreciate it go get
the tickets in New York City theater at
MSG it's gonna be fun and we got special
guests and I'm not going to tell you
you're just gonna have to see it to
believe it and might have a show on Vice
City I know it's called the super
maximum retro show every Tuesday 10 p.m
Eastern Time
[Music]
how you doing you feel good I feel good
I feel like you first of all you're I
that sweatshirt I love it oh I'll get
you one all New York Knicks yeah logo
whale super Comfort whale bone hat we've
talked about them shout out well bone
love whale shout out whale bone I'm
designing a hat with them I told you
designing a hat with whale bone we
weren't going to go on a trip to Costa
Rica with them but we're not going oh my
God I have to tell them that oh you
haven't told them that they texted me
the other day but my flight info I said
here's the bed I can't go I they sent me
the info when I realized I couldn't go
and I I literally been so busy I forgot
to get back to him it happens yeah well
I'll get back to them before they see
this that you just reminded me can you
remind me to tell them that reminder
yeah can you can you fabulous lightning
when I'm done can you be like you gotta
talk to a whale bone today we have Pat
Pat Yamaha yeah in the back again
Lebanese lightning
like you it's easy to remember now
Yamaha with an S yeah what is that what
is uh that's Lebanese like the Smith of
Lebanon it is very common oh wow where'd
they get Pat from uh we all my uh
siblings have saint names because we're
Catholic okay oh so what are your other
siblings names actually I don't know if
Joanne is a saint name sorry but it
isn't it is now Anthony and uh myself
you have a Bartholomew no what's the
funniest Saint name
um what's the what's the oddest Saint
name what's your confirmation name
Anthony Christopher Paul Anthony
DeStefano what about you it's Michael
Michael what's the funniest Saint name
Google Google funny saint names
um Saint salt birth
[Laughter]
I went to Saint Matthias school a lot of
people don't know Saint Matthias who's
Matthias Matthias was the one Matthias
was the 13th Apostle Matthias was
Matthias was a backup he's like capadana
I swear to God after Judas got clipped
he was the father he's an apostle yeah
he was like a apostle he's a capodana
yeah yeah it was the backup wow birth
Satan birth one is really funny Saint
berthoud's good birth
um do you know what's so funny the other
day I was see I saw it coming if the
show's been on but it's sometimes the
names of shows are so funny it's about
this show is about a woman who comes in
and she's like this badass woman and she
works for a family and I think she's
like
I I don't know what the premise of the
show is but she's like can fight and do
this and do that and the name of the
show is the cleaning lady no no have you
seen the pr the show is Google the you
know the show the cleaning lady your
description was very confusing what's
this what's the premise of the show the
cleaning lady it's just such a funny
name for a show yeah the cleaning lady
how did you just describe this show
is the cleaning lady canceled he said
it's a woman who does things okay so
what the actual premise is is it's a
whip smart Cambodian doctor comes to the
U.S for medical treatment to save her
son but when the system fails and pushes
her into hiding she uses her cunning and
intelligence to fight
but she's be cup so she was a doctor I
gotta be honest even that description I
don't know what the show is about let me
read that again oh okay we know it's
about a whip smart Cambodian doctor okay
comes to the U.S for a medical treatment
to save her son but when the system
fails why would the system push her into
hiding though listen she uses her
cunning and intelligence to fight back
breaking the law for all the right
reasons listen here's the truth if
Walter Hauser is not in it what's his
name Philip Walter Hauser his name is
his name is
Paul Walter Hauser if Paul Walter Hauser
isn't in it I'm not watching I don't
know that's my new yeah that's my new
2023 goal yeah if Paul Walter Hauser
isn't in it I'm not watching it we
should make t-shirts that say that yeah
we should just make t-shirts and say
Paul Walter Hauser yeah I love you get
mad if we started selling merch with his
face on it
um
merch I don't know what if we genuinely
care well people people make they do it
all the time they do it to me and I
actually don't like it right but it's
it's it's it's it's literally like
thousands of people I mean it's like
it's like I'm losing I mean there's
nothing you could do with so much money
is being purchased with the merch that I
don't own it's insane right but like I I
just don't like when they use my image
but then I'm like what am I gonna do
really I guess yeah I think that he is a
cool dude have you ever met him I
haven't but I I
know some people who met him and know
him and uh he's actually a wrestling fan
because he was on the day after he won
the golden Global best actor he was on
aew which is wrestling on uh TBS and if
they're in the same family Network that
I'm in as a matter of fact this week I'm
going flying out to El Paso Texas and
I'm going to be on aew Dynamite and
Rampage and they're doing a segment on
my show because the I don't know when
this is airing but season 10 of Joker
start says airing February 9th shout out
so they do live shows on Wednesday and
then Friday so you and the guys are
going to go I'm flying out to El Paso
we're gonna be on live Wednesday night
Dynamite on AW not just I don't mean the
seats we're gonna be involved wow I'm
hoping I'm gonna be able to get into the
ring and take a and take a hit is that
like if you do that like is that is that
well you it's a dream come true dream
come true they said that we could do a
storyline and I could even wrestle uh
they they mentioned that we'd have to go
to training for like 12 set 12 weeks or
12 sessions which you don't have I don't
have time to I have to go to Atlanta for
like you know 12 days can't do that I
can't but this one they said that we
could at least be part of the storyline
like part of a a little like a little
gimmick that night or whatever right and
I I get in the ring and stuff I'm
actually kind of very nervous because
it's like I don't know
yeah I mean I think that I'm not nervous
I'm super excited I'm just if I'm gonna
take a hit I want to make sure I look
good doing it you want me to hit you a
little bit Yeah you can slap me around I
think that you're but you're such a
wrestling fan yeah that I think that
you're just gonna know I think the thing
the key with wrestling is they know when
people the fans know when people are in
there not you know acting stupid right
they acting out the pocket right and you
know that you're not that guy because
you know the story you know the energy
right you know and that was it you and
the other guys or is it just you it's
giving me the other guys uh but Paul
Walter Hauser was on AW the day after he
won the Golden globe with his Golden
Globe and he was like backstage doing it
like he was part of the show so he must
be a cool dude because he could he's
he's the best actor for this year for
the Golden Globe but he also is
literally going ahead like a wrestling
event because he doesn't you know what
he he does he takes the advice that we
gave last week on the show for my
grandfather Yeah he knows that no matter
what he's leaving this planet on a box
like the rest of us bwh no so he pwh
knows he's a cool cat I like I like Paul
housing we've dedicated two episodes now
to Paul Walter Hauser man should
continue to do it yeah well no this
episode is dedicated to him let's do it
every week like how every every night
for no reason Jimmy Kimmel would just
say Matt Damon we ran out of time right
right we should do that for Paul Walter
I love it I just get him on just we're
mention them every week yeah so tell him
you know as always this show is
sponsored by
Paul by Paul Walter Hauser and and the
rest of the people and Co right um I uh
I um yeah babe and I um I I can announce
now too that I'm hosting a show on Vice
it's called the super maximum retro show
about the 70s 80s and 90s and there's a
chance if if we ever do do more I wish
that sounds coming you're coming on
because we talk about wrestling Chris
gethard was on in the in the in the
trail I saw I saw that we're talking
about wrestling old fun stuff from the
70s yeah wrestling was wild yeah man
forget it dude it was crazy because
people believe K fave wasn't like a
thing yet okay fave is the the concept
that we're all believing that it's real
you know what I mean okay not breaking
character basically so if it's kfabe
it's in this reality of the universe or
the storyline and they commit to it but
now because the internet where things
have come you watch it and people like
offline you'll see the real wrestlers
and and what's really going on behind
the scenes and you they're real
Instagrams and social back in the day
wrestlers weren't allowed to break kfabe
so in public appearances or anything
there was no internet so it was like you
had to keep up the the belief if you saw
the ultimate warrior in the airport he's
acting like that yeah well he's not like
he's not running around like shaking
people screaming he's not in the paint
but like he's wrestling's real in other
words right what's going on in that ring
and and everything you're seeing is is
it is funny what an impact wrestlers
have on people my cousin was telling the
story once she was on a flight
um from New York to Tampa once which by
the way I'll be in Tampa April 1st Tampa
theater is on sale
um I or it's going on sale tomorrow I
think it's on sale but Tampa she's on
her way to Tampa and she sees Hulk Hogan
there right just do me a favor before
you even go there Tampa theater
Tampa Theater okay make sure your dad
gets here early there's no parking
okay right and all you fans that are
watching right now if you're gonna go
see Chris at the Tampa Theater you have
to get there early there is no parking
no parking people turned around and went
home because they couldn't find spots
after like an hour yes in life and you
shouted my father out who was Sid you
thought was sitting in the crowd but he
wasn't because he turned around and went
home that's right because I was talking
about him on stage and I asked where he
was and I was looking for him great
theater right it's great it was great
the end of the show's so intimate
intimate show right on top of you shows
were hot I love the crowds yeah yeah and
what's the hotel in Tampa what's to go
to uh uh I had to get back to you right
right I'll have to get back to you um
Sal's got the best hotel wrecks but it's
just it's just the thing is with I
didn't stay
I didn't stay I drove to Orlando uh uh I
drove to Orlando I'm driving from Miami
I got Miami at the font on Blue the
night before I'm in Miami [__] yeah I'm
doing a lot of Florida in March you ever
go to Florida a lot I'm going to Florida
I got Jacksonville yeah uh Fort Myers
Orlando
Miami West Palm Beach and Tampa okay I
did Jacksonville Tampa I I think Tampa
yeah Tampa is the place I'm telling you
about
Jacksonville is the Florida theater
Tampa okay I got the place I got the
place I told you about this the place
for you to eat you have to go you have
to go where where what city it's in
Tampa it's I went there remember I told
you it was an insane old place like 10
different rooms yeah and you go upstairs
and there's a whole there's a whole
Space there's a whole restaurant
upstairs just for desserts and you sit
in these little booths that look like
barrels and it's music playing you could
pick up a telephone and talk to people
in the other booths no I didn't tell you
any of this no this can you can you
Google famous Tampa Steakhouse yes I we
they gave us a menu we called and they
were like oh we don't deliver us
whatever it was we're like do we just
want to go to it it was the best one of
the best dining experiences I've ever
had so I have to go you think I gotta
make rezzies you make a res maker we
call last minute they accommodated but
they were just being very nice Charlie's
Steakhouse no Fleming's Prime no Burns
burn Steakhouse dude you got to go to
burn Thursday
Disco Inferno burn baby
that looks like an um that's like a
steak burger no do burns do interior
like can you look at the interior of the
place so the thing is the thing is
there's a bunch of stores back a hundred
years ago and the guy ended up buying
every store and connecting and
connecting and connecting them outside
it looks like a Christian bookstore or a
strip club it's a white stucco building
but it's inside it's all these stores
connected and they all are from like
another era dude and every single room
has a different design and it's super
old school and when you go in the uh
even in that Lobby in the entrance way
it is wild there's all these old
paintings the big stairway that goes all
the way up because you go after the show
or before this after the show so you
went out like 10 o'clock at night I went
late yeah right and dude the service was
amazing it's it's hard to undersell this
place and then so they're known for they
took us down to The Wine Cellar it's
like the biggest wine cellar in the
United States or something like that
that yeah that's the one and then and
then the guy's like so you gotta save
room for dessert because upstairs shout
out burn Steakhouse shout them out I I
have the I have I have a contact for you
I have the contact so I'm getting in
because and and my show is on Saturday I
can eat sweets on Saturday I can only
eat sweets once a week oh Saturday oh I
got you covered I I believe I can't
remember I don't know specifically but
I'm pretty sure the girl that works
there might be a hey babe fan oh God if
she is hey what are you doing oh she's
in here oh no she's a Joker's fan she's
a joker it was her dad but sometimes
they watch yeah
what happened what's going on
oh bring it here come on walk on no just
just give it to me just Jazz please
[Laughter]
oh that's really nice
I'm in love with a man yeah
Oh I thought you were calling me a man
oh but you are did you shave the message
I'm kidding thank you Jazz I appreciate
this
um
sorry I I treated her like I'm telling
kids oh wow yeah nostalgic you're
nostalgic for it I can't oh
I uh okay all right so he says to us you
gotta save room for dessert Because by
the way by the way I just want to let
you know you know what everything runs
on Duncan good and if you don't believe
it take it up a Bloom Cafe that's all
you got to say okay uh he goes there's a
there's a restaurant upstairs part of
this restaurant it goes with the whole
top floor is our dessert restaurant okay
so you don't have dessert here you go
upstairs you have dessert and there's
like 50 desserts
and can you name can you name two of
them yeah they have they have they have
root beer floats they have uh pumpkin
pie they're cheesecake they had all this
cool stuff but also they have like stuff
that they created
using like using like uh what's that
[__] the Gastronomy what's that [__]
Gastronomy yeah yeah all right they have
stuff that they created like they
perfected it okay and so the dessert is
great but the steak is good too the
steak was unbelievable but this thing
you know she she's telling us about it
because you go upstairs he goes and this
is the owner no this is just one of the
waiters that's been there for like 30
years and the girl and the owner wasn't
there but anyway
they say you're gonna sit upstairs in
these pods and they're meant to
represent like look like barrels okay
okay and so they're your own pod so you
go up and upstairs and everyone it's
dark it's like a lounge it's really dark
and everyone is sitting in these private
pods that look like wooden barrels and
you kind of like you walk and you don't
know where you are you get lost and you
look and there's people in these spots
and in them
is a it's a it's a thing on the wall a
panel with five buttons and every button
is a different style of music old music
so you can push the button and play like
can you request to sit there every part
those are the pods and you walk see you
don't see anyone's tables because
they're all behind these these little if
you just click on there you'll see it
and then you can put like hit one thing
and it's like 1930s Jazz and it it's
this whole did you sit in the Pod I did
and that's where you enjoyed your meal I
was with Steve burnt yeah we all went
upstairs with Steve Burn After it burnt
yes yes and that's why and that it's so
that's why we do this show that's why we
do it and then every one of those pods
has a phone in it and if you pick up a
phone at the same time that another pod
picks up the phone you got connected to
them and you can talk to them but you
don't know who they are or where they
are in the in the building did you try
it yeah yes you're talking to people
dude I never see anything like it you
got it you got it you got to connect
click right there uh let lightning right
to the right now go to the right uh no
so it's the entryway right there so no
okay okay so wait so go click on like
this middle Center there with all those
lights yeah yeah that's a picture from
the top of the steps looking down at can
you expand that that's what it looks
like when you walk in dude dude that's
amazing so I gotta go with Tampa Tony I
gotta go at myself oh you go get a table
of six get a table of six yeah okay how
many did you go in there with one two
three four five six one two three four
come on baby say you love me five six
seven times eight nine ten eleven I'm
just gonna keep on Counting until you
are mine
hey babe Hi how are you
um so okay so I'm so happy I remember
this because when I walked away from
this I'm like I will never I will never
go to Tampa without going to this place
now give me that same recommendation
that same energy for Jacksonville
uh I gotta let you know Denny's going to
Dennis I gotta let you know Jacksonville
is a tough cookie you know Jacksonville
is the second or third largest city in
the United States from a geography stand
point the the largest really I think
actually Jacksonville might be the
largest city in the United States
geographically you know what second
Philadelphia just from a geographical uh
Point not people so just land man
Houston I think yeah yeah do you like
topography
topography meaning like Maps yeah yeah
like but they're raised Maps right isn't
it fun when you see the landscape Escape
isn't that what it is it makes me feel
like I'm blind though you know like it's
a break oh yeah yeah do you know
topography do you know what we see on a
map right like what you believe Florida
will look like or whatever it's just
that's not what it looks like
they have to the way you have to make a
map when you put it flat like that and
all that they have to like go Google
what the what the what the countries or
what the planet really looks like like
how do I say this like you mean
because the way a map has to be flat the
way we look at it it distorts what the
actual shapes of the countries really
are so when you see it like in its
actual State supposedly like a satellite
yeah it doesn't look like what we think
it looks like it's like a little off
hmm I don't even know how to tell Pat to
I don't even know how to describe what
should Pat type I think patchy type what
do
what does what do the countries really
look like from space when map isn't flat
topography [__] let's see what comes
up yeah
interesting a picture of Maya Angelou
yeah
yeah okay so that looks pretty on par
I can't explain it to you you haven't
okay
uh what what does yeah what does America
really look like from outer space
what does America look like really what
does America look really look like from
outer space or really look like yeah put
in really or some type of like adjective
you know yeah like in italics yeah like
yeah
I really like using italics the juice
sparingly It's very effective just yeah
do you use italics
you ever throw italics into it like a
note or an email
not recently not like when I like to
stress something or point it out it's a
bold option there's an underline option
and there's an italic option sometimes
when you like really want to go off the
deep end you bold underline 9 how often
do you use your laptop how often are you
sitting typing at a desktop or a laptop
true sometimes all day long sometimes
not at all that day so you're using a
laptop often yeah yes I am because I
have to uh it's mostly the reason I
really use it the most no yeah I do I
use it for a lot of reasons all the time
but I have to edit a lot not me editing
but like notes on editing for my to show
and stuff so I'm always like watching
the edits and giving notes and
everything I have to write a lot of
emails I know we could do like emails
from our phone which I usually do but
like no I do have to use it you don't
use it a lot I don't think that I truly
do you have a laptop I have a laptop
I've never seen you I've never seen you
hold open type or use a laptop I'm going
to tell you the God's honest truth right
now yeah I have not opened my laptop in
maybe six months everything I do is from
my phone to the point where if you said
if you wanted me to you know copy and
paste something from a Macbook I don't
know how to do it I don't know how to do
I'm so computer illiterate yeah it's
wild but because I just do everything
from my phone now you can do everything
for me like if I wanted to write a a
script I can just do all that's tough
that's tough yeah but do you you you
research everything from your phone
everything I do is on my phone is that
weird because I I I see people like I
was on a plane your your cell phone
pornography exclusive I I've never
watched porn on my laptop once okay I I
don't even think about bringing a laptop
with me in my on the airport everybody's
got their laptop I don't even I don't
even consider it do you know why I bring
in a lot of times and you might just do
this on your phone but if the tell it's
if the television in the hotel is [__]
like if it's not a smart TV and I want
the option to watch all my programs I
bring the laptop a lot of times for that
because I could lay in bed and turn it
on it's almost like a small TV screen
instead of like having to look at my
phone but what you just don't even I
would but I could but I feel like every
TV now you can just stream whatever
you're watching from your phone onto the
TV but if not if it's not a smart TV
right sometimes you get screwed that way
well I think for me typically when I'm
alone in the hotel room it actually I
like to just get out and like walk a
little I like to like not be post show
though well post show at the night
pretty much like clockwork I I go back
to the room
um I masturbate and I go to sleep that's
almost like almost like religiously what
I do okay and I've got usually fall
asleep to Sports Center okay so you'll
you'll get it you always have ESPN yeah
yeah because because I just I'm usually
so tired after the show yeah
um so I but I don't I don't but you're
more of a night owl than I am so I would
understand why you would why you would I
usually have my routine is I don't eat
before any shows I don't eat before
shows I hate it I just don't like to get
full or tired or you know anything can
you just turn so destroys the other way
I appreciate you and I love you and you
love this fantastic this works Zach
going that way yeah you have fun with
that there it is um so what I do is I'll
bring my food back after the show and I
have a whole routine
[Laughter]
I'll smoke a little bit not always
though and then uh and then you know I
don't like to sit up and eat at the
table Yeah I grew up you're past that
did you grow up sitting laying and
watching television from the floor yes
my entire life and my whole family were
floor like there was a couch but we had
carpet even in my in my grandmother's
house and I laid on the floor all the
time and watched television when I I'll
tell you what I do like when I'm home
like when I come home whatever me and my
daughters are typically always sitting
watching TV with our backs against the
couch on the floor and you know one of
them sitting in my lap and we'll just
sit and like it's just easier to do that
and when I was a big kid with I was a
big TV dinner tray kid my mom had a tray
that she would pull the legs out yes put
it in front of me and then put my plate
on there yeah those old old school
that's what I would always say I would
always have a dinner trip absolutely
yeah and she would have like and for
Christmas I'd get different dinner trays
they get a Yankees one
yes dinner trays are not a thing anymore
or no because we're not we're not kids
anymore I think they're a thing I
actually still I saved my smurf one you
have I have two of them I have two my I
saved them do you ever use it the little
the little fold out they're the ones
that you could sit in bed and like and
put over your lap to eat right but then
I also have the dinner trays like the
old school ones with like the wheels on
them they unfolded like flimsy right and
they just yeah my grandparents had those
shits I saved them yeah like that right
yeah yeah right sure yeah look at this
oh can you go to the one all the way to
the right yeah let's pull up this one
this is the one I'd like to get you for
Christmas yes that would that's a that's
an interesting one nice big penis one
but I used to also in turn then I also
used to lay on the floor to eat oh
that's cool wow I used to lay on the
floor to eat I didn't give a [__] I
would lay like all my [__] I I have a
habit like Leanna pillow and I would lay
on my stomach on the pillow and then I
just put my food in front of me okay and
I I did that all the way like you're in
Greece yeah like before I moved to the
place I was in
my last place the kitchen uh you
couldn't see the television you couldn't
see the living room from the kitchen I
could see it I wouldn't just you when I
could see your living room from the
kitchen you couldn't see it but I could
see it what do you mean you just you
actually you just weren't thinking that
you could see it but this whole week me
and your family saw it okay you didn't
see it okay well we saw it from but you
couldn't see it okay well now I could
see it okay but I couldn't so I I didn't
never ate at my table I wouldn't just
sit I lived alone I wouldn't just sit at
the table and Eat Alone the meals right
I'd always want to eat them in front of
the television of course so there's two
ways to do it you can eat over the
coffee table which is primarily what I
do now because I still don't eat at the
table right but I used to lay down in my
old place and and I used to put down a
vinyl uh tablecloth on the floor not
full like I'd fold it so it would be
like a like a maybe like four feet by
two feet and I'd lay my whole meal out
and I just eat watching TV laying on on
the floor yeah so when I go back to the
hotel I don't like go to the little desk
and sit there and eat what I do is I lay
on the bed and I eat my meal on the bed
nice sometimes if I order room service I
wheel that right up to the edge of the
bed and I lean and I eat off of that but
a lot of times what I do is I don't want
to stain anything right because it
happens yeah so I get a towel and I open
the towel at the edge of the bed and
then I arrange it like it's a table and
I put all my stuff on the towel and then
I lay on the bed and my head's at the
foot of the bed with the towel with my
meal in front of me and the TV right in
front of me perfect that's my routine
let me ask you that while you're
masturbating I'm setting up the towel
well I have a towel set up too but okay
different rights right but but you
let me ask you this is a big thing yes
when you get room service let's assume
you're by yourself sure see me by
yourself when you get room service do
you have as much as they insist on it do
you have the person who brought up the
food bring it into your room and set it
all up or do you take it from them into
the room by yourself do you wheel it
yourself because they are they insist
yeah to bring it inside up and I don't
like it I don't like it I'll tell you
Mike from square one I want to keep them
out of the room I don't want you in the
room yeah I'll give you more of a tip if
you just let me do more of the work
they're like can we can we come in no oh
my God I got it a lot of times it
depends sometimes they'll bring up a
tray and then you got to take the tray
from them and then the door slams well
sometimes what happened to me once I was
insisting nobody come in the room I just
didn't want I said he was like no please
I'll give it to you I was like no I I
will take it in I took it in and he
didn't tell me that the food was in a
hot box underneath I didn't know how to
open up the HotBox I had to call and
bring it and he had to came back up and
I felt like an [__] yeah yeah
absolutely I'll just say oh just you can
put it right here you know what I'll do
sometimes I'll open the door and I'll
and I'll judge the person first okay so
I'll open the door and if the person
just looks like they don't give a flying
[__] or they don't know me or it's like
sometimes it's like a 80 year old Asian
guy yeah I let him come in yeah come in
but if it's like anyone like that's like
has any sense or yeah I'm just like no
you can stay out there I'll just take
her home yeah yeah yeah I I it is it is
a weird and it must be weird for the
hotel employee who has to do that
because they probably don't want to come
in but they're told you need to you need
to push your way into that room yeah and
set up that goddamn you tip additionally
always tip included always always I do
too you know what I've been doing lately
you ready for this please 40 yeah I've
been going 40 a lot of times cash
in a hotel room
no in like a restaurant oh you you've
done why would you do that why would you
do cash I just feel like the economy
that's kind of messed up right now you
you do cash for them
so let's say we let's say we come out we
got a meal we you and I got a meal let's
say it's a hunch yeah I put the credit
card yeah I put the hunger on the credit
card write cash and you leave cash cash
I write cash where it says tip and I
leave you 40 cash I think that they
appreciate that more because in some
places I guess you don't have to report
the cash tips or your report tips but if
it's cash you could decide what you
wanted yeah then they save a little bit
on taxes but not every place someplace
it doesn't matter they end up banging
them out for the taxes anyway no matter
what yeah I think I I just feel like
I've been in the mood like you know mode
you know what I've been doing lately
um and I've always done this but then
you go through phases where you don't
like my initial response a lot of times
I guess because just fear like say
you're at a red light or you're walking
past someone and someone you know
homeless comes up to you it's like can I
have a dollar you know your initial
thing it's like whoa I don't want to
open the door but now I've just been
like even if even if that person attacks
me which is less likely I've been doing
Jiu Jitsu once every two weeks so I feel
capable to handle myself and if I get
pink eye I get pink eye on the the time
now because of the kids so even if they
throw their urine in feces at me I'll
deal with the pink eye I give them
whatever I can a dollar a quarter
something food and it's just if you just
do one act like that of kindness a day
it is still selfish because you're doing
it for you but you make them feel better
but you feel great yeah if you just do
it once a day and then one usually it's
never usually just once usually turns
into multiple once you pop it can't stop
it's Pringles why don't you pop it can't
stop it's like Pringles when you give
homeless people money it feels good and
you it's like it's like a sour cream and
onion prank yeah well sometimes I put I
wrap dollar bills around each individual
Pringle chip put them back in give it to
the homeless person the whole thing yeah
I am the type of guy who more than not
when someone approaches me will actually
give money like I I doesn't freak you
out I know you want to give the money
but we have to be I always want to give
and I always get like I'm always like
because they say like oh they're just
gonna they might buy drugs and OD all
this stuff well I mean it's their life
do what you got to do yeah it's My
Prerogative do you ever get food it's my
life I I told you I do get food right
the guy sent me to the store for him
yeah I was late I was going to actually
I was going to Dave Smith's pod uh uh
special tape shout out to Dave Smith is
the Samaha of Lebanon Samaha right is a
very common last name in Lebanon right
it's like the Smith of Lebanon so if
Dave Smith is from Lebanon his name
would be Dave Samaha right and if you
want to you know you know commit a crime
or do something where you need to just
blend into the Lebanese you you rename
yourself somehow yeah what's the yeah
what's up what's a what's a common first
name
Aziz Aziz so if I said hi I'm Aziz
nobody will matter to be anybody you get
lost in a crowd yeah yeah that's right
is John Smith that's our John Smith wow
shout out to zamaha yeah I mean how many
of them are there right it's like Patel
yeah
yeah so okay so you you have to go like
so in Italian yeah yeah so Dave Smith
there was a homeless guy there and uh I
I had extra food I what was it it was a
uh rigatoni Bolognese no I I I forgot
what it was I brought I had blueberries
from home a thing of organic blueberries
and I had a leftover food or not left I
even left over it was a salad I didn't
need something like that I gotta
remember but I got out and there was a
guy there and he's like asking for food
and I went over and I said oh I have
this if we do like it and I gave it when
you opened up he's like nah I don't
wanna and I was like oh what what you
know I forget exactly what the food was
and I I was late right so
I gave him the food and he goes I don't
want this and I was like oh I don't know
what to do I'm late and he goes well can
you just go in and buy me something from
over there and he pointed to a Dunkin
Donuts and I was like
all right he was yelling at everybody I
told you the story once before he was
yelling at everyone that walked by and
it was really weird and so I went I gave
him he said he didn't want the salad it
was a brand new salad he goes but you
can go into Dunkin Donuts and get me he
said something like a frittata whatever
it was I don't know and I was like I was
like but I'm late for I think it was
just go you just go get it and did you I
went I said yeah I'm gonna get a few I
walked to Dunkin Donuts I got and there
was a line I'm like oh God damn it like
I'm gonna be late like once they close
the doors on a special tape and you
can't get it take it in so I'm waiting
on I'm like all right let me just wait
online I waited online like five six
minutes I get up there they don't have
what he likes
so I think I went into the store I think
and got them blueberries or something
now I went to the next door he said
something about blueberries I brought
him in I gave him it right and I because
they didn't have what you want so they
gave him something else I'm [__] the
story then I go to Dave Smith specialty
and when I come back out I walk past him
oh he's still there and he's screaming
cursing me out and I'm like I'm the guy
from before that waited online for you
in Dunkin Donuts yeah I offered you one
meal you turned it down I went to Dunkin
Donuts I waited long I didn't have what
you wanted I went to the deli I got you
something else I'm like I'm that guy you
call me you just call me a [__] idiot
and but because it was like it was like
he never we never had a relationship
well like it's one of those things where
you PR I would assume probably heavily
on drugs right I don't remember probably
I would the thing is sometimes I knew
the story I really [__] that story up
it was not entertaining it wasn't
cohesive and it was probably spotty on
what actually happened because I really
forgot I've told a story before but I
gotta go back and think don't you hate
when that happens it was a wonderful
story I used to tell it and people I
used to like that because it was a real
fun little ditty yeah and and I I it
happens to me more often than not that I
can't remember something a funny turn of
events you know what's a thing that
you're there's new research now that's
saying that they think that you inherit
memories do we speak about this where
when you have a child or your child or
your mom or dad no passes their memories
to you no to your subconscious and Deja
Vu might be one of your father and
mothers or grandfather grandmother's
memories popping up and that's why you
feel like you've been there before
because you have but it wasn't you do
you believe that I do believe that
makes some type of sense to me our
memories inherited and then also and
then dot dot dot what do the what do
what does Lebanon look like from space
yes correct topography question mark
[__]
what is Bluetooth Chris Bluetooth is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis but in chewable tablets and at a
fraction of the cost and it comes right
to your door discreetly you can take
them day or night okay you can plan
ahead or it's ready whenever the
opportunity arises listen not everybody
likes to swallow pills it's a lot easier
to chew yeah I'm a chew guy I like you
I'm Chrissy chews they call that's what
they call me and I like blue chew
because I can still get the same effects
as we said as Viagra Cialis but I don't
have to swallow it I chew it and the
thing I love about Bluetooth the most no
doctor visits this is done online sign
up at bluetooth.com that's all you got
to do there's no awkward conversations
it comes to your door in a discreet
package these these tablets are made in
the USA and it literally Bluetooth is I
use them I got friends that use them at
nothing but rave reviews with Bluetooth
and I'm telling you right now you can
actually get it for free it if you use
our promo code this is serious right now
go to bluetooth.com put in the promo
code hey babe all you do is pay the five
dollar shipping and you're gonna get the
first month free first month that is a
month of free erections on Bluetooth
it's a beautiful thing bluetooth.com
promo code hey babe five dollar shipping
fee
at first month is free thank you we
thank Bluetooth for sponsoring the
podcast and that's basically it babe if
you can benefit from extra confidence
when it's time to perform chew it and do
it have better sex sponsor rocket money
burning all of your subscriptions rocket
money used to be true bill used to be
rocket money I think is one of these
companies that we're gonna look back in
20 years and be like that company
changed the world changed like an Amazon
like a Microsoft rocket money formerly
known as true bill it is a personal
finance app that finds and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps you lower your bills
all in one place how many times Sally
retro do we literally forget about a
subscription we have and then we're
paying all this money rocket money finds
it cancels it all the damn time everyone
has that problem they solved a problem
right okay and I I recommend this to
everyone I know even my family has it
all yeah because I know my mom doesn't
know how to cancel subscription my dad
doesn't know no given this they signed
up and that's it this is one of those
things that there's no reason there's no
reason for you not to get it no reason
for you not to get in over three million
people which actually was the ratings
for Impractical Jokers last week three
million people have used rocket money
saving the average person up to
720 a year that's a lot of easy so stop
throwing your money away cancel unwanted
subscriptions and manage your expenses
the easy way by going to rocketmoney.com
hey babe that's rocketmoney.com hey babe
rocketmoney.com hey babe
that's crazy I I that I never thought of
that concept and it makes so much sense
yeah while theories about the
inheritance specific memories have been
thoroughly disproven some researchers
have asserted that more General
associations formed by previous
generations can pass from generation to
generation through genome but this is an
old Theory because the new research is
saying they believe it to be true
possibly posible really yeah it's it's
oh that's fair that's unbelievable
wouldn't that be wild I told you about
the story with my daughter
did I tell you how sense of humor is
inherited and I have the proof of that
did I tell you I have the proof of that
no please so
I um uh Delilah my daughter my my
youngest one she was about three right
in preschool whatever go to pick up from
preschool
and
um the teacher is there and she goes
she's laughing she goes your daughter is
a riot I was like oh really I said she's
rioting what's what's going on right and
I said is that what you're teaching in
the school because I support it but I
just I'd like to know if she's going to
be at a riot right and and she goes and
no she says she's a riot she's so funny
I said what what happened and she said
you know I've been a preschool teacher a
long time yeah she was like your your
daughter you know a lot of times kids do
the same Joe they pull a ponytail they
flick a booger it's the same bits pretty
much
they're all they're all hacks
she said your daughter did something
that I haven't seen in any 20 30 years
I've been teaching I've never seen a kid
do this she went in the back and she
started you know it was time for
dismissal she started putting on
everybody's coats you told me this she
put on hit me with the headphones
so I'll say if people did she started
putting on everybody's it was a long
time ago she started putting on
everybody's coats and I was like oh my
God how it's so funny whatever you know
laughing and silly you know a silly
little girl whatever
took her to my mom's house that night
telling my mom I'm like ma the baby did
such something so funny so what you do I
said she put on all the kids coats
showed you a photo yep my mom like was
like wait what goes to my room comes out
with a box of all the photos pulls out a
photo of me at three years old putting
on everybody's everybody's coats already
on that's that's never spoke about it to
my daughter never she had no idea did
you inherit it a bit you think that she
basically is a joke Thief then yeah
yeah okay yeah yeah it wasn't parallel
thinking I I don't think it was it
wasn't parallel I think Joe Rogan
actually made a video about her okay
about other instances where she stole
okay so we don't know if she could be
trusted fear is out there in her face
aren't she fears in her face in school
right yeah yeah
because I remember because she was also
told me that joke about well uh you know
if if you you know if you send all the
Mexicans back who's gonna build the wall
yes yeah she she stole that for me yeah
yeah yeah and and whatever but hey it's
what it is but that's an instance where
I have proof of that's so cool though I
have a sense of humor she did and even
like it's weird like when you have kids
like
they just do like some of it's just like
learned behavior but some of it's like
you know like like the way like the way
she sleeps is like my mother I said this
to me like she sleeps like you yeah like
she's contort like she's your body's
just it's just like we have the same
brain chemistry yeah it's weird that's
cool it's cool it's a cool weird thing
um but yeah I uh I don't know I think
what you know talking about the memories
and and like all this like new updated
science stuff is kind of like
nuts and all these like conspiracies
coming true it's it's do you think that
we'll be able to download our mind or
memories at one point one day like like
do you think that I I I don't really you
know like even pimple talk about how
everything's a simulation and things
like that
I mean it's not a simulation right we
just it
I don't it's just I don't think it's I
don't understand how they're saying that
we're going to be able to transfer like
they're going to turn this into like
some type of like digit like coding like
how are we gonna download or preserve or
transfer memory that's what they're
saying I've read articles well because I
think that they're saying now upload
your life memory to a server like how do
you I mean yeah I I don't know exactly
the science behind it but I think that
what they're saying is is that just the
advancements we've made in the last
40 50 years in technology like we're
very close to most likely being able to
like or probably already have like
cloned someone and things like that and
I think that they're saying that if
we've Advanced this quickly in just 50
years wouldn't it be logical to think
that we've gotten so Advanced that if we
are a really just a product of advanced
civilization we are that advanced
civilization is so Advanced that we
would not even recognize that we're not
real we're not the base reality right
we're a product of the base reality but
then in a sense we are still the base
reality because let me remind you every
step towards the goal is the goal
don't forget that it's about the Journey
of course to the destination and that's
important every step towards you go hard
to practice what you preach but that's
true my goal is to to one day do stand
up at Madison Square Garden so every
step I take every show I do from the
village Atlanta to the Maui Taco to uh
to to to to to uh the my Tampa Theater
burns after to my corporate kick at
DraftKings to the shows we have on sale
in Fort Myers and Jacksonville every
step towards that goal is the goal every
show is Madison Square right right
because the point because it's
irrelevant your destination is
irrelevant it's the journey to the
destination yeah and also let me remind
you this my brother today are the good
old days I know so stop reminiscing
about the good old days because you are
living in a good old day right now this
is basically the therapy I had this
morning at eight o'clock
[Laughter]
dude I'm not even kidding like I have to
that's something I'm working on in my
life right now like genuinely working on
happy birthday thank you so much yep
yeah oh God yeah yeah so you're
genuinely working on what I on that yeah
no really that because like it every
single we will be like remember when we
were sitting in your thing doing our
podcast one day like don't you wish like
I missed those days so every single
moment is the good old days and it's you
know it but it's hard sometimes to
to accept it and act as such The
Nostalgia that we were talking about
last episode about kids and all that
this is Nostalgia today oh yeah we're in
the Nostalgia you're in the nostalgia in
the good old days always I know my
father is in his mid 70s and we'll talk
about good old days from 10 years ago
when he was in his mid 60s and we're 30
years away from that I said sing it
sister so it's like it's like you just
have to stay in the present and remember
everything is happening now I understand
I know and I have this thing where I'm I
long for the past the Nostalgia I have
trouble being present and I Fear the
Future
and and that's not a good place that you
want to be and even when I I dig deep I
dig my heels into the fact that right
now is the Nostalgia I then get anxiety
because it's just slipping through my
fingers in the moment I think what in
the words I think in the words of Elsa
from Frozen Let It Go is what I think
you need to do is let it go because I
think that
you you you you actually gain more
control of your life when you step back
and try not to control it I understand
that uh
but my genetic composition my brain
chemistry is such that I can understand
that be fully aware of that concept
agree with you but still not achieve
letting it go what a battle lobotomy I I
see that or I gotta just buy don't sweat
the small stuff and read it a few times
oh that or the four hour work week you
can read Tim Ferriss the four hour work
week many retirements and go on many
vacations
it's all about it's all Tim four hour
four day work week four hour work week
Tim Ferriss Tim Ferris wheel but what
what what does that imply a four hour
work week in other words sign me up in
other words you know you got kids let's
say let's say I got rather than trying
to work your whole life to to retire
forever be retiring and going on
vacation while you're living your life
you know let's say this
I got three kids right let's say I you
know I got my kids sometimes it's hectic
you know three band beans
I get them all strapped into the car
seat uh rather than
got my kids in a safe spot rather than
just running into the driver's seat
going to drive dealing with yelling all
that
as I shut the door as I shut the door of
the the kid in the back say rather than
walking to my right right into my car
seat right into my driver's seat walk
around the back take five seconds for
yourself to take a mini break a mini
vacation in your mind kind of settling
breathing air not thinking about them
knowing they're safe and just kind of
living in the moment just for five
seconds sometimes five seconds all it is
then get in the car and prepare yourself
now you're back at work
uh rather than taking a rather than
rather than working hard to say I'm
going to take a year off work hard work
take a year and then every two weeks if
you can you know like say with the
business we have take a day off yeah
well you're doing nothing don't let
everything roll into the next into the
next into the next you always have
enough time to take a break always I
understand even if it's mini breaks in
many retirements and then the four hour
work week kind of says rather than they
need you to be the government wants you
to be a slave to the clock that's why
they set up school has to be at this
time and this and everything is
regimented because the more time you
stay in that box though you're more
tired the less time you have to think
the poorer your nutrition is it's a
whole thing next next and he says get
out of there are you saying the the
function of the government
I'm putting words in the book okay I'm
now I'm now I'm just adding a chapter
This Is Now by Tim Ferriss and Chris
Stefano this is the new updated for our
work week on hey babe but he's saying
that you could take a break in the
moment when you're working and then just
get into that psychology where
you're not I got what you're saying so
like for example like
hey yes Sal's on vacation right now so
but he said I can go ahead and do the
show without him
um while he's on vacation it's just a
quick vacation he said it's it's mini
um and that's good you gotta rest but
yeah uh I think um
oh did I tell you guys by the way I got
the vice show coming out I got a vice
show coming out uh March 7th is when it
starts uh produced by Jimmy Kimmel I'm
gonna be doing the couch on Jimmy Kimmel
show um that'll be fun and um all new
stand updates we've added a fourth show
at the Wilbur in Boston a fourth show
christycomedy.com for tikiwickies
um and a whole bunch of new dates Texas
San Antonio awesome oh sounds back for
vacation how was it dude I feel relaxed
actually yeah right yeah yeah uh yeah
someone told me that you're going to
Boston when's that yeah March so we had
we had put two shows on sale on March
24th they sold out in like the first
show this never happened before the
first show in the Wilbur sold out in
like an hour Boston rocks and the Wilbur
Rock sells out like that we're doing um
then the 25th is we added two more shows
so now we got four shots are coming out
no this is probably two weeks I think so
last week I played though two with the
Wang
at the Wang yeah how was it it was
fantastic but see the thing is we
haven't been able to take a break
in the middle yeah there was an
intermission and I many intermissions
that's what yeah little intermissions we
uh we didn't know because I haven't been
on tour with the guys now the practical
jokers tour is on right now 50 cities
impractical jokerslive.com every week
and we're out check for your dates check
for your cities uh last weekend check
this out what happened last weekend we
weren't in I haven't been on tour with
them in like three plus years so we this
is the pandemic yes so we didn't know we
didn't know how to gauge what venues to
play again so in some places it's
theaters in some places not going wood
then God bless you it's still like an
arena right whether it's lowable full
whatever it is someplace so in Boston
the last time we played there we played
TD Bank
TD Garden which by the way no
disrespected tea to Garden but we think
Chase the chase is better
I'm not gonna get into that right now
okay because that could get bloody that
could get bloody but uh but anyways we
didn't we didn't know if we should book
The Garden again and so we booked
Madison Square
CD Garden Oh in Boston we didn't know
right I'm because I played there last
weekend Boston so we did two wangs the
Wang's a 3 500 a pop and it sold out
right away so we could have done the TD
Garden right it's sold out in what like
a less than a day so it sold out so
before we before 7 000 tickets no not
less than it yeah it's just what if you
could sell 7 000 tickets in let's say a
week or two's time well you could you
could keep it going you said we could
have sold another Wang and now you're
getting into 10 500 which is the TD
Garden so we didn't do it but the night
that I was at the Wang for two shows Jay
Big Jay oakerson was next door to Wilbur
and Bert was at the TD Garden and
Berkeley the same night we were all
there together wow and it's almost like
it hasn't yeah I was gonna say it hap
and see this is the thing with time in
February it happened February 4th yeah
it happened two weeks ago but yet it
still hasn't happened right right
because you just like everything's
happening at once so what's the
difference if it happened two weeks ago
or if it happened next week right it's
all happening everything everywhere all
at one which I heard is a fantastic
movie you should see it is it is it is
it worth it to see it's fun yeah what a
good um a good title everything
everywhere all at once it's a bit wordy
oh do you know the did you see did I
tell you to watch his new Nicholas Cage
movie I probably didn't you probably
didn't
the unbearable weight of massive Talent
no I think that's what it's called he's
a new movie with Nicholas Cage where he
plays himself it's
unbelievable really so good so funny so
much fun uh I left out loud throughout
the whole thing
lol.roflma Pascal I love Pedro Pascal
he's great they're both so good in it
dude you gotta watch this movie okay
okay all right the unbearable weight of
man of massive Talent we're gonna watch
yeah there's good you're gonna like it I
promise there's good movies out lately
yeah right maybe my two favorite words
in the English language what are they
hellofresh I love it America's number
one meal kid folks now number two number
three you know what marches number three
would be impressive number three number
one what March is is not only is it is
it International women's month shout out
it is National nutrition month is March
and hellofresh makes it easy to choose
delicious dietitian approved meals all
you got to do is look for The dietitian
win tag on the menu choose for meals
under 700 calories and with one third
less sodium babe that's what it is you
want to power up a protein yeah do it
it's easier than ever with hello fresh
just check the protein smart tag on the
menu quickly find recipes featuring 30
grams or more protein like one pot pork
and black bean chili or creamy Dijon
dill chicken I love it hello fresh makes
it easy to eat what you love customize
select Meals by swapping proteins uh on
size or even adding protein to a veggie
dish and now you can even upgrade or two
organic chicken or organic ground beef
on selected meals yes I love it and
right now you're going to get a great
discount all you got to do is go to
hellofresh.com hey babe60 and use the
code hey babe60 for 60 off plus free
shipping we say it every week we do not
know this company makes money we don't
give so much food away for free yes all
you got to do one more time
hellofresh.com hey babe60 use the code
hey babe 60 60 off plus free shipping
hellofresh America's number one meal kit
would you want to be a movie actor uh do
you see that next would you like to be
in a movie I'm not gonna like say that's
what I'm do yes I would I would like to
do that yeah I sound like I want to be
like that's my job but I I really want
to investigate that I really like what
do you want to do when the Joker's ends
what do you want to do yeah I want to do
stand up and I want to I'd like to do
some scripted whether it be television
or some movies so that's where you're
gonna put the energy in I think into
developing all the shows and then also
going out of my own di like out of my
own Circle and participating in in
someone else's problem you think you
could take a break do you think you
could say I'm a guy I want to just do
three months of just nothing
I will I have to probably do that you
think you're going to do that I'm dying
to do that yeah I'm dying to do that
right so the four hours
I still don't understand let me just be
let me why is it a four hour work week
I'm gonna be upfront and honest with you
I read about five pages okay listen and
then listen you took a break yeah took a
break and then listen to a few minutes
I've been on an audio podcast so I don't
have on an audiobook I'm sorry so I
don't really have the answers yet but
what I want to do for you is over the
next two weeks see if I can finish that
book and then kind of have more insight
into what I've learned I don't want to
put them will work on you you got to
take a Pilots
okay no there's actually actually you
want to know here here wait you know
what oh okay you know what let me um let
me uh hold on because I just got to get
my hand I'm gonna can I can I take a
mini uh just a just a two second mini
retirement yeah okay yeah absolutely
okay let me just guys I'll tell you what
impracticaljokerslive.com for tickets uh
we're doing February 16th in North
Charleston we're doing February 17th at
the Spectrum Center in Charlotte
February 18th at the Del Lago Resort and
Casino in Waterloo February 19th at
Capital One arena in Washington DC March
night Niagara Falls March 10 Prudential
Center in Newark March 11th the Toyota
dome in Wallingford March 12th the UBS
arena in Long Island Shout Out New York
Islanders uh and it goes on and on Green
Bay Milwaukee Rosemont Seattle Portland
Utah Denver Arlington Austin Sugar Land
where we were last year Schottenstein in
Columbus rocket mortgage fieldhouse in
Cleveland is going to be a good one and
so on and so forth Detroit man are you
back from PK hey help are you done yeah
I'm done just keep it there's even more
dates in that and
practicaljokerslive.com and practical
jokers live.com we kicked off the tour
uh this weekend you did yeah I went to
Reading Pennsylvania good good part of
PA for a douche and I went to uh we
actually did a
Stony Brook Long Island we did the
college for two oh I love Stony Brook
they would see kids were awesome they
were awesome is that what they are yeah
didn't speak about that but yeah uh and
it was the it was the first time we did
this material in that kind of
environment
it came together good I can't believe it
but it actually came together like
because we were just running podcast
shows at all the clubs for like the last
three months and uh it just [__] all
came together and we had four shows this
weekend and they were all [__]
slammed amazing good yeah I'm happy good
way good to be this weekend oh well no
it doesn't well we'll do the dates yeah
yeah we'll do it but I want to tell you
because I don't know when it's coming
out I want to [__] it up so I found this
Instagram it's from the spread love
movement it's originally from sahil
Bloom of Cafe take it up with solid
he'll bloom
so he says today is my 32nd birthday
over the last month I asked what are you
reading me right now I'm reading you uh
something from sahil Bloom but but but
he emailed you no this is something that
I found on or or I think my friend Brian
might have sent this to me it's from the
spread love movement Instagram account
oh I'm sorry you said that repurpose
from Saw he'll take it up with Bloom
Cafe okay so it's at South hillblum on
Instagram but sahil Bloom Cafe on hey
babe okay so he says today is my 32nd
birthday over the last month I asked
several nine-year-olds what advice they
would give 90 yeah I love it I love what
they would give to their 32 year old
selves here's the life advice everyone
needs here and I'd like to read some of
it and I know this one now and then
break out the fancy China and drink the
good wine for no reason at all I love it
dance at weddings until your feet are
sore I do it tell your partner you love
them every night before falling asleep
someday you'll find the other side of
the bed bed empty and wish you could oh
I didn't hear the end of that don't fear
sadness as it tends to sit right next to
love
sadness and love sitting right there
when you see someone crying hysteric
when you see someone's uh somebody said
this I forgot who it was but in ancient
Greek hysteria from far away Thomas when
you see someone yeah yes when you see
someone laughing hysterical or crying
hysterical from far away you can't
determine which one it is they're just
hysterical so this is what he means by
this sadness and love is right there
they're very close to each other okay
don't fear sadness as it tends to sit
right next to love
treat your body like a house you have to
live in for another 70 years
I treat my body like a [__] Airbnb
rental uh yeah a 24 hour you're treating
it like an Airbnb rental in Miami on a
bachelor right now that's exactly what's
happening here and I need to take that
advice it's my temple never Raise Your
Voice except for at a ball game
do one good deed every single day but
never tell anyone about it give the food
to the homeless don't tell anybody about
it go to Duncan for the homeless that's
it time doesn't heal anything when it
comes to relationships don't delay
difficult conversations
find the things that make your eyes
light up do more of those
always remind yourself that your track
record for making it through your bad
days is perfect
you always oh that's an interesting
that's an interesting
these two shall pass if something has a
minor issue repair it minor issues
become major issues over time applies
equally to love friendships health and
home it's just minor we all have minor
issues right now go and repair them the
most damning lie you can tell
is the law you tell it yourself yeah I
knew that one no one has every no one
has ever argued their way to happiness
can't argue your way to happiness you
either got it comes from within so
you've got to just feel it well
OJ got acquitted
it's a good point there's a caveat in
there sahil Bloom what about OJ If
You're Gonna Lose a fight make sure the
other person thinks twice before
fighting you again
that was a little bit different than the
rest of them that that one seems like it
came from like a World War II veteran
getting old is no picnic but it's much
better than the alternative
getting Young yeah yeah yeah I'd be
passing yep yeah what it is it's an
alternative I guess yeah not being here
at all yeah yeah rather be here than not
be here you may occasionally disappoint
others but make sure to never disappoint
yourself
wow I mean a lot of this stuff is great
advice it's tough to practice all this
plus when you walk away how do you
remember all that it's I know you got to
put it into practice but never let a
good friendship atrophy send the text
make the call plan the trip good
friendships must be treasured oh I agree
when you meet someone look them in the
eye give them a firm handshake and call
them by their name
that's the advice that someone said that
they would give theirself from 60 years
ago yeah yeah it's just shake your hand
and call everybody that one was like
some of them are singing Someone if I
was like hey you're 90. would you tell
yourself when you were 30. I would tell
people to shake shake it here's a good
one give everybody a second chance but
never a third
so this is now changing a little bit to
a little bit more we're having different
different kinds of nine-year-olds I like
this remember if someone doesn't even
give you [__] them if yeah oh here
here's a good one the good old days are
always happening right now that's the
one that's the one and that that should
be good but that also gets me depressed
I don't know why here's another one
which again I don't know how to take
this one whenever you hug someone make
sure they are the one to let go first so
that's good advice also yeah it's a
creepy old guy yeah that was good advice
then but as ever since about
2016.99 now
if it's raining on a warm summer evening
go outside and dance in it
okay A bit of a pneumonia risk yeah
you never know but taking no risk is the
biggest risk you can take regret from
inaction is always more painful than
regret from action sure it doesn't have
to be how many 90 year olds does he talk
to I think he talked to uh all of us a
few more okay it doesn't have to be
perfect for it to be wonderful okay I
love that when in doubt love we can
always use more love I agree with that
looking presentable is a matter of
self-respect
when you're feeling down smile at
yourself in the mirror for a full minute
that seems psychotic that's wild that's
a psychology guy that this is someone
who has schizophrenia yeah that's a guy
that definitely got hit with some
shrapnel travel as much as you can
collect one token from every trip to
remember it by
hey I mean we're trying to not be so I'm
trying to I'm trying to do the opposite
of that yeah yeah it's too much clutter
and also it's like it's got Metro call
nobody does tokens anymore right
everyone's got some digital yeah yeah if
there's something bothering you ask
yourself whether it will matter in one
month if not let it go right now you do
this one yeah different wordings yeah
months don't give it more than five
minutes okay that's my wording but it's
the same okay stop trying to change
people who don't want to be changed it's
not going to happen you may win the
argument but if you lose the friend what
was the point
okay
stubborn pride is the downfall of many
men and women learn to forget the slight
hurts and avoid grudges I agree with
that do one thing that challenges your
mind every single day a crossword puzzle
math problem anything daily exercise
will keep your mind sharp for the Long
Haul if something isn't working and your
gut tells you to try harder first ask
whether there's just an easier way to do
it
allow your kids to fail you will hate it
but it's very important that's tough man
tough to yeah tough my kids are my older
ones failing without you know even
trying so that's good she's good she's
got she's got some issues with math
um there's nothing wrong with shedding
old relationships as you grow and change
that's another big one we've talked
about that before whoever you are today
you may not be that person 10 years ago
because we're all just bags of chemistry
we change you don't have to bang your
head against the wall if the
connection's not there yeah yeah yeah
uh no amount of money is ever worth
trading for your peace of mind okay
debatable but yes okay but it's out
there no I I fully agree I fully agree
on that hey if your kid wants to dance
in line at the store join them that I
agree join them hell yes that's my
favorite one so far smile and say good
morning to strangers on the street I do
it last one laugh loudly and
unapologetically whenever you feel like
it that's another psychosis one yeah
freaking Joker yeah I I I what'd you
think of those I I liked it I like them
a lot it's a lot to take in and a lot to
process and to remember to put into
practice right A lot of them would
things you know I've heard a lot of
things were saying things we've heard
different ways uh I wonder if I should
like read those things more often like
daily like reminders like you know I
mean follow sahil Bloom Cafe on
Instagram okay well I'll send it send
that to you you know what I realized
recently I was I I realized I was high
at home I had I had one in an auction uh
a newspaper from Back to the Future from
the movie an on-screen newspaper that's
pretty cool from Back to the Future too
I wanted at an auction and it's like
it's one of my favorite movies I got it
framed and it's up and and it's the
movie right now in in
2025 will be full
40 years old wow okay and I and I I got
this in 2015 at the 30-year anniversary
okay so now I've had it for eight years
and the the newspaper has yellowed that
it was when I bought it they had kept it
sealed and it was like nicer than it is
now and when I went to get it free it
was a lot of money I want to get it
framed and I said to the guy is there
any way to keep this from like yellowing
and he's like not really not unless you
mount it on linen permanently and then
it stuck to linen so I don't know if
it's because it's a newspaper that kind
of opened up I don't know if you're
going to want to do that so I and I
passed on it
it's yellowed over the years this is a
thing one of my like things I love that
I paid a lot of money for of my favorite
movie that's supposed to bring me joy
it's hanging in my hallway and every
single day every single [__] day when
I pass it I get anxiety because I'm
watching it get deteriorate and get
yellow and and get literally the quality
of it's getting ruined as it hangs there
in my lit in my thing it's I'm supposed
to walk by that thing and get joy from
it and the thing I love I walk by all
the time and I I just realized that the
other day that I knew I was getting
stressed but I'm like every time I pass
that I'm stressed out because I'm
watching it this year and I go up to it
every few days just like to see if my
eyes can pick up on the fact that it it
has gotten more deteriorated move it
move it to a place you can't see well
what I realized is I should just go back
open it up get it mounted on the linen
now because it'll stop progression and
it might regress the deterioration I'll
do that yeah but it will in essence
destroy the newspaper in its form which
was where the value was applied but then
I said to myself I bought that to enjoy
it I'm not looking to turn it over
because of the resell yeah so why not
just get it online because it's mine
yeah it's for me so I'm going to go back
now I'm going to have it open back up
and run through the process and that's
what you do but it was wild for me to
realize that something that I passed by
that was one of my favorite possessions
that's supposed to rejoy that exact item
every day when I walk by it was giving
me Stress and Anxiety yeah I still is
right now because it's still hanging
well that that happens that happens too
with like uh not you know similar but
different where again sometimes you want
to have so much control but you realize
like you're not in control and sometimes
having less control gives you less
anxiety like you know the world we live
in it's like I wanted you know when I
sent my kids to school Apple Air tags
watch I gotta know where their location
is all the time I feel like I'm going to
want to be like that I stopped because
it was giving me so much anxiety because
if the thing didn't update yes or
whatever so now we should just open the
door walk out and just be back by five
Let It Go and there's no anxiety yeah
because I'm like God forbid if something
happened God forbid yeah we I will deal
with it I've now made a commitment to
myself I will deal with things as they
come if nothing is dealt with I'll stay
happy because I've just let go I've and
I've also let go about like you know
like I I've put the same value on time
and money so now it's just correct
that's big I don't need to necessarily
add the extra night or add the extra
show what I need is to is to have more
time back yeah so I'm like make enough
money God willing that you can have your
life that your family wants but it's
like at so many points now I just try to
to find time yeah I don't care because
because you're always going to have
people in your life who want you to do
more always yeah but you can't really
listen to them because they're not you
it's so hard to learn how to say no and
to learn how to Value time but it's like
you get into this machine where you also
feel like I need to store as much
[__] acorns for the winter as
possible I just liking myself to a
squirrel but uh like but it's like you
want to take care of your family right
and so you want to work as hard as you
can because especially like I I when if
you come from kind of pretty much not
nothing really you know and you find
yourself where you you in a position
that you're successful and you can take
care of your family like I don't know I
just I always like put it on me to be
like you had to take every opportunity
because you have to take care of your
family and you want them to be in the
best possible position yeah but what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do then
one one day when you drop dead and then
they're going on without you so it
wouldn't matter I I agree and I'm so I
think I think I feel that way but I
don't always put into practice but I'm
hyper aware of that so yeah I mean it's
a what you told the line between [__] it
and no this does deserve a little more
attention for me I say to myself I it's
always a value of the time away versus
the money so I'll say if you want me to
go away for more than four days then it
has to be enough money in my opinion
where I now have the opportunity to not
have to go away at all again for like
another month oh no for sure I'm with
you there but I mean the [__] it like in
general like what you said like uh just
let go and I'll deal with it if it
happens like how do you like that whole
like ah [__] it this what it is what it
is how do you like how do you balance
that attitude between when that attitude
is could become detrimental at some
point like in some side by just trying
my damndest every day to stay in the
present I think about I I just stay in
the president I say whatever is going to
happen issue I'm going to have to deal
with tomorrow I'll deal with that issue
tomorrow I feel like you really do do
these things though because know you and
like you'll give me that that you'll
you'll save stuff like that like advice
to me like that but then I actually see
you doing it I really do see you doing
that like you'll you'll say to me like
just you know like a lot of times when
we're just having like you know give me
advice and you'll say something like
that and then I'll see that you've put
that into practice yeah I I uh I commend
you for that thank you well you do work
at that ship I'm trying I I just kind of
feel like I I think and the reason why I
you know World Works in progress but
because you know my daughter's kids
getting a little older and I realize
like hey they're gonna start to like
absorb things for me subconsciously so I
want to try to be the best version of me
even though I will never get there but
at least attempting to be so what
they're absorbing for me is at the very
least my best shot at who I want to be
as a person and you're there I mean
there's a formative I mean you're they
are taking more notes off from you they
can realize yeah there so all that
subconsciously how they're interpreting
the actions the way you speak what you
do everything everything is being
absorbed right now yeah the reason that
people are so [__] up and go to
therapy they half the time is to get
into therapy undo everything that they
learned from unlearned from their
parents yeah because my take what I I
listen I you gotta as a parent you know
I I you know you always hear well you
have to put yourself first because you
have to be happy so everyone else can be
happy which I agree with but I do feel
them my main job as a human now it is
not comedy it's not podcast it's number
one is Dad Dad so I think about that
first is number one is how what kind of
that is the just the most important 100
so what what is so how can I be the best
father so when I think about it from
that way most of the things are well
you're gonna have to be a better leader
then and you're gonna have to be a
better version of yourself and you're
and all those things and then what
starts to be become clear almost
immediately is money is not important it
is it is never oh you need more money
they don't care about the money yeah
yeah yeah it is all these other things
so it starts to make me feel like okay
well I'm gonna then take less
opportunity and less money but it'll
make me a better dad hopefully because I
I'll be home and with them and then
things move and then and then that's how
I think about it yeah and then and then
Chas Department I'm sorry not Chas
um who told me something that actually I
just had another profound change uh
recently thought thought pattern is it
Samantha Bloom uh no it wasn't Samantha
Bloom although Shadow Bloom Cafe
unbelievable vegan cupcakes and sweets
and really great food at Bloom Cafe
um and uh um it was um who was it who
was it who was it who was it who what
what where where was I just last week a
very profound Louis CK with Louis CK was
on uh the Christy chaos podcast here uh
yeah and so I said to him you know he's
a father got two girls I got two girls
and and he said um I said to him you
know I'm thinking now I'm young you know
whatever my kids are young so I'm gonna
do this thing or it's like I'm only
gonna try to go out one or two weekends
a month in most situations I'm gonna try
to be home so much because I've said
listen they're they're little kids now I
get to be with them whatever when
they're 18 then that's when I'll go go
on a [__] bus tour in a world tour
because they're gonna not want to you
know want to be with Dad anyway and
they're you know whatever and he goes
you have that all wrong and because he's
his children are older now and he goes
you when you get older
when your kids get older your time with
them is more valuable because they have
less time and you have less time you're
closer to death and they have less time
because they have their own lives so
that one day or two hours a week that
they have free to see you you need to be
there so he said so your time actually
becomes even more valuable and becomes
you you should be on the it should be
even less as you get older he said so
rather than thinking about I gotta do
this or that he said he said just think
about think about what the time versus
the money value is he said because once
you're a father
and you have kids then they will always
be the most important thing in your life
and you'll always have to make a
sacrifice for them with time away from
them he said but I'm telling you the
time away from them as they get older is
more precious and more valuable so your
thought process of oh when I'm 50 I'll
go on a world tour is all wrong he said
if the world tour happens if the
opportunity presents itself now then you
should take it now but you should do it
once he said if you get an opportunity
just specifically for comedy yeah you
should only do it once he said if you're
going to get to that Mountaintop
go around once because you're not
supposed his he had great advice said
you're not supposed to be at the top of
the mountain for for that long you get
there's no air up there right you're
only supposed to do that [__] once then
you come back and then and then you know
kind of like get a cruising altitude
through life okay have a spike you know
like that's interesting have a cruising
altitude through life he said and that's
how you can be that isn't he on his like
fifth World Tour though no well yes well
now well now he's well but a lot of the
advice that he gave was because he it's
because he lived through it I got it so
it's so so but but that
but that's how I think about like with
the [__] attitude and all that stuff
is like I just think about you know
um like my time my time with them versus
my time away from them and
kind of not putting every emphasis on
money not putting it all on money and
kind of taking it away
time taking myself out of it and and
also kind of being protective of my own
energy just being protective of my own
energy with the thought of I want the
best parts of me and the most amount of
my energy to deal with my kids and my
family sure sure so I try to at the very
least when I'm out working expend just
the amount of energy that I'm
comfortable with and not anymore with
with like uh um like be for example some
of the fans at uh the podcast where uh
asking me why don't you meet and greets
anymore if I came out through the back
door and there were 50 people there
wanted to take a picture I would take a
picture with every single one of them
right the reason why I stopped is
because I did the same I would charge
them for a meet and greet and I hated
the way I felt because I just thought
the act of this is wrong for me it felt
like I'm taking money from someone who I
would do this for free actually Maddie
Healy the lead singer of The 1975 my
favorite band said it and it kind of he
articulated in a way that I finally
under stood it and felt like that's what
I've been trying to articulate he said
if you're doing meet and greets right
and you're out there
rather than going through Ticketmaster
or through your agent
have the fan give you 25 cash have them
give you twenty five dollars cash and
take the pick and see how you feel yeah
you wouldn't feel that way after the
show if you put a hat around because you
just gave them your work right that's
different but you would feel that way in
the meet and greet and I was like that's
how I feel so I stopped that but even
more that it would take so much energy
for me at I realized how incredibly
tired I was after it because you are now
doing another goal of your energy and it
should be in between shows and they add
to the second show and then you never
stop no and you're talking the whole
time you're thinking the whole time it's
mental exhaustion so I said I'm not
doing that anymore I'm giving them my
performance which is what I craft each
and every day I would gladly take a
picture with anyone if I saw them but no
more I'm stopping my I'm stopping to I'm
not just giving my energy to everybody
all that's why I got off social media I
was responding to too many people
talking to too many people letting too
many people's personalities letting talk
to people's opinions affect my
personality I said all that is sucking
my energy I need the energy for the kids
yeah so that's what's changed yeah yeah
I mean the perspective that that's
that's the perspective you got to have
and you know people don't know your
experience if a fan comes up to you then
certainly not thinking of anything from
your perspective or experience and a lot
of times people want more from you than
even just a nod yeah or even a picture
is stopping you know but like and like
they don't realize that if
30 people do that to you in a day you're
that that cumulatively is like 20 15 20.
it's 30 minutes 30 minutes a day and
it's like well I gotta go get back to
this I gotta do that I gotta do this and
it's like you you have to as as much as
it sucks you have to be like this is I
have to this time has to be for me yeah
so that's what I try to do try to I
think like you know be be careful with
your energy I think is a is a is a big
thing but one thing about the kids now
though is like the young kids is like
they they they never grow at such a
rapid Pace both physically mentally as
they do now so I feel like now is
is something that if you miss it you're
never getting it back but then if they
hit a certain age they're kind of like
established in you know whether it's
teens or 20s like they're that person
and they're changing and they're growing
and things like that but like it's not
at the rapid pace of like zero to you
know 15 years old you know what I mean
so it's like I feel like
you you know your time with your kid
from when they're 25 and 28 and 32 is
going to be somewhat similar than like
your kid at 3 7 and 10. yeah I think I I
agree I think too like what I think
about you asked before like what do you
think like with the [__] it attitude I
think also if as far as I have a
confidence enough in just myself like
you know I went that's why I think
education is important because I you
know I love what I do now with comedy I
really do but I still have the physical
therapy degree and the doctorate so I
feel if even if I stop taking
opportunities and whatever and I just
feel I'd always make at least enough I'd
be able to find out and get out there
and and at least make enough money that
my family could be comfortable and
survive yeah so I when I think about it
that way I'm like okay so then if that's
the case then why do I need to do uh you
know all these dates in a row and always
being all over the place and I don't
need to because I feel like if we got to
a point if it's about money I'll be able
to make the money what I won't get back
is the time with them yeah was it but
it's the nature of our job though you
have to grind and if you're not
someone's taking your place right and
you had it's momentum it's always
forward it's forward momentum and I
that's what I feel I always get nervous
if I stop down that momentum of me you
know getting better at what I do or
having more people come see me that's
what I have to reconcile because it's
like I work so hard to get here and like
you said it's the journey so I had to do
all that to get here right and I had to
keep doing it to get here and if you
know if I want to get here whether it's
just before you know because I want to I
want because I love comedy I wanna I
wanna get to this point in comedy or
because I got this far and if I can
achieve this you know I got this far all
I need is to push it this much more and
I'm going to bump to it but then see
even even what you're saying yeah is
you're not it's not you're never you're
not living in the good old days you're
not living now because you're like
everything becomes well what about the
next thing there is the next thing is
there is no next thing right whatever
you did is it happened did you ever
think about
taking exactly what you have right now
and figuring out how to make that last
and what your budget should be based on
what you have right now and just
retiring right now and living like a
life where you can just 100 of time do
what you want like you can only do it if
you make a certain save a certain amount
of money but like I I think about that
like if yes oh oh no no sorry Jasmine's
just looking at me oh okay oh we had
time oh are you are you do you need me
no okay
um I would think about uh yes I even
mean like for me it's not that you're
rich I just mean even if you like go
live in like
like Cambodia or something or even like
a place in like the the you know like
like I don't know like the Poconos go to
a place along with cost a living yeah
low cost
um I do I have thought about that a lot
but then again I what it would take me
from again just specifically about
comedy is I mean I would do the comedy
for free we started when you first start
doing comedy you do it for free you
actually lose money you have to pay a
club to get on stage so I so while I
would say yes I know what you mean to
retire and just do whatever you want but
I kind of feel like I do whatever I want
really anyway you know so I kind of feel
like I I I I I I I I don't know that I
would do that only because I feel like
again then without having something to
be motivated for for me I'm just like
living in the you know Poconos or
something because it's a lower cost of
living and and I wouldn't have to go out
with a gun against my head to make money
um I feel like my quality of life would
probably go down because I'm not doing
anything that I find like stimulating
yeah I think we're stimulated people
because we grew up in a an urban area
yes right so we have we have stimulation
as opposed to people that grew up in the
countryside or wherever that is right
people that have much simpler lives yeah
but probably maybe they have to clear
our heads but I do Daydream of being
like dude I just want to wake up go sit
on my porch look at rocking chair like
like you know what I mean like like why
can't you do that why do you feel like
just that like just like like like like
like just like retirement like just like
why don't you take any retirement why
don't you take why don't you go for a
month and rent a Airbnb a house I'd say
in the calf skills and just do that for
a month and just see because maybe after
a month you'd be like I don't want this
is actually it's almost good sometimes
to do that to kind of sit in what it is
you think you want yeah and then you
either realize like I gotta go towards
that or you'll realize man I don't want
this look at Hannibal Buress Hannibal
Burris wasn't feeling motivated by
comedy so he just said I'm leaving and
he was like a guy who did comedy as much
as we did it was wild said I'm leaving
and I'm doing music because he just
followed his gut which is he's probably
happier than it oh yeah everybody yeah
because he left you know and he does his
own thing now and it's good for him you
know I don't know that you I don't know
she's the best
um so I don't know okay well
we really got into it that's it this is
uh This was um you know what this is
Pat's fault this this all was Pat
shamaha's fall to Dave Smith of Lebanon
Pat's energy in here made us made a
different hey babe and uh and and and
we're not doing the show anymore this is
the final hey babe yeah this is it
usually usually I I get a little more
introspective when I'm around the
Lebanese
the Lebanese they're like they're like a
human they're like human Ayahuasca the
Lebanese they made they opened up a
third eye on us all right let's go get
some kebabs hey babe
don't be a fake don't be a flake don't
run away from your feelings babe don't
be afraid don't be ashamed don't
hesitate to say hey babe hey babe hey
babe hey babe
[Music]